salut antoine ébats salut merci pour
avoir accepté mon invitation même si en
réalité c'est toi qui nous invite
puisqu'on aujourd'hui chez 3 ouais c'est
vrai ça c'est c'est une invitation
l'invitation j'irai dormir chez vous
et vous voilà en tout cas merci à toi
est ce que tu pourrais te présenter
brièvement et nous dire pourquoi nous
sommes ici aujourd'hui alors présenté
brièvement donc antoine de maximy
62 ans
retraité quasi c'était vrai que j'ai pas
fait d'études donc je prends ma retraite
plus tôt
et on est ici alors je fais la série
j'irai dormir chez vous ça c'est
l'essentiel c'est l'actualité en ce cas
depuis une quinzaine vingtaine d'années
et on est ici parce qu'il ya deux zèbres
qui m'ont si vous vous rappelez et qui
vendit tient dimanche ça serait bien et
que sa mallette tout à fait voilà donc
l'émission j'irai dormir chez vous que
tu animes depuis combien d'années
maintenant 18 ans et à 18 ans le premier
tournage et qui a repris récemment
puisque pendant la période qu'ovide
c'était un peu plus compliqué ben ouais
ben j'ai fait un long métrage et voilà
tu as fait long métrage on va en parler
on va dire nulle comme au juste pour
informer nos spectateurs sûr j'irai
dormir chez vous sur quelle chaîne
keller qu'elle joue alors maintenant en
ce moment c'est sur rmc découverte qui
est le canal 24 de la tnt ça veut dire
tout le monde peut le voir c'est gratuit
et c'est tous les vendredis soirs bon et
bien rendez vous est pris pour nom voilà
tu l'a mentionné on en parle un petit
peu parce que trouve que c'est
intéressant tu as écrit
réalisé ou co réalisé un long métrage
dans lequel man réalisé jalili ouais
voilà dans lequel tu es l'un des acteurs
principaux est ce que tu peux nous dire
dans quelle optique dans quelles
démarches qu'ils étaient lorsque tu as
voulu faire ce film est ce que c'est
l'envy de te frotte au monde du cinéma
parce que ce sont tes voyages qui t'ont
donné l'idée de faire quelque chose de
scénariser c'est les 2 c les deux
j'avais envie de me frotter au monde du
cinéma ça toute façon mais depuis
toujours quand j'avais quinzaine
d'années je voulais faire du cinéma
comme beaucoup de gamins et en fait j'ai
eu énormément de mal à faire ce film
parce que venant de la télévision et
voulant faire un film sur une émission
de télévision est un film de fiction sur
une émission qui est totalement
improvisée et il y avait une espèce de
contradiction il y avait de nombreuses
contradictions qui ont fait que personne
personne n'a voulu faire ce film n'a
voulu mettre un sou sur ce film mais ça
je m'en fiche parce que j'ai voulu deux
présentateurs personne ne voulait
jettent tout ce que j'ai voulu faire
dans ma vie tout le monde personne
pensait que c'était une bonne idée donc
maintenant avec du recul l'expérience
des années je me suis pas arrêté mais
comme ça n'avançait pas je veux la faire
courte mais j'ai lancé un financement
participatif de 16 mai 2019 et un an
après alors quelques vides c'est à dire
le 26 juin 2020 on faisait la première
projection publique c'est à dire je n'ai
pas un centime rires le scénario écrit
les producteurs qui étaient là mais pas
un centime pour faire le film et un ans
après le film est tourné et projeté il
est sorti et il sortira au cinéma en
septembre donc ça c'est un peu de têtu
voilà mais justement c'est ce que
j'allais dire et la transition est toute
faite parce que ce qui transparaît la
bombe lorsque tu le raconte un peu
l'histoire de tarifs commencer d'avoir
dû surmonter à chaque fois les obstacles
et doit d'avoir mené des projets à mon
bras
syndicats tempérament persévérant oui et
puis surtout je pense qu'il ya un truc
qui est important c'est aimer se battre
parce que sinon c'est vraiment trop dur
quand quand tout le monde est contre toi
que personne ne croit à tes idées ou
quasi qui est vraiment obligés de
d'enfoncer les portes et il faut aimer
ça en fait moi je j'ai un autre projet
de film qui sera beaucoup plus dur à
monter c'est une histoire complètement
fantaisistes qui se pare d'or qui se
passe dans la mort et donc en plus pas
triste assez gai c'est fou c'est bon ça
va être hyper dur c'est pas du tout là
où même les gens qui aimaient même la
série qui m'aime moi m'attendent donc
ça me motive ça d'abord tels motifs on
va en reparler on va en parler alors une
première question peut-être un peu vague
quand on te dit philosophie ça t'évoque
quoi alors moi ça m'évoque jamais votre
machine en fait parce que je discutais
avec ma fille quand elle est justement
lé vétéran je commençais à rousse était
la mère de ma fille je sais plus enfin
bon qu'ils n'étaient pas en train de
faire des études vont parler de
philosophie et est en fait moi je disais
fille c'est pas compliqué enfin le dire
il faut il tout juste d'avoir des îles
et savoir où tu te positionnes raconter
expliquer comment tu contourne tu
négocies tu tu réfléchis sur la vie et
tu prends du recul 20 avant et elle m'a
dit mais ça n'a rien à voir ça n'a rien
à voir quand tu fais des études de
philosophie on touchpad ne doit pas
expliquer quelque chose tu dois citer
des gens tu dois aller et là je me suis
dit pourquoi la philosophie comme ça
c'est pas pour moi très bien plus une
philosophie toit de terrain d'expérience
de vécu vêtements complètement
philosophie de tout à fait le taff et
est donc ça m'intéresse beaucoup ses
interviews parce que je pense que moi je
vais découvrir les choses bah on n'a pas
eu souvent je crois à l'occasion de
proposer des interviews philosophique
non non non je crois qu'il y avait un
journal psychologie qui voulait me
laisse pas tout à fait pareil n'est pas
du tout et mais ça n'a pas abouti donc
une belle bon alors le mot voyageurs
semblent en apparence bien te définir
mais est ce que ce n'est qu'un aspect de
sa personnalité c'est à dire est ce que
tu penses que le mot voyageurs ne suffit
pas à définir ton rapport à la vie ton
rapport au monde oui c'est même
carrément insuffisant c'est insuffisant
ou le voyage moi j'en ai quand même pas
mal besoin et j'ai besoin moi même du
déplacement
c'est à dire que je vais souvent voir
des amis et que j'ai un peu tendance à
privilégier ceux qui sont pas à côté
parce que j'ai envie de faire la route
parce que la route c'est un moment qui
est très important pour moi c'est un
moment de vous je me ressource parce que
se déplacer alors c'est peut-être parce
que je suis un hyperactif et que j'ai à
peu trop de choses qui se passent dans
la tête mais que le fait de conduire
prend une partie de mon attention et
qu'après le reste est beaucoup serein
alors que sinon j'ai vraiment du mal à
me concentrer sur une chose d'accord
voilà et d'ailleurs qui est un truc
bizarre mais ça je sais pas s'il faut le
dire mais le sujet c'est que chaque fois
que j'ai eu un accrochage j'étais pas au
téléphone à quand je suis au téléphone
ça m'arrive jamais je suis vigilant oui
et quand je suis pas au téléphone j'ai
je rêve au lieu d à ce moment là je pars
loin oui et je suis beaucoup moins les
petites loin quand tu pars dans tes
pensées oui il compta jusqu'à diviser de
tondeuses par rapport à la réalité est
ce qui se passe autour de moi d'accord
aussi meilleur téléphone légalement
c'est à dire avec un équipement pour
l'autoriser
là pas de problème mais comme versée bon
alors la marque de fabrique de ton
démission c'est je veux partir aux
quatre coins du monde oui n'a pas dit et
ce qu'on doit le dire ça comme ça
s'émeut l'émission pour ceux qui
connaissent pas je te laisse présenter
le concept aux élections ont corrigé la
personne ne connaîtraient pas ouais
alors le concept date car je veux redire
à eux le concept de l'émission en fait
c'est pour ceux qui savent pas très
court c'est le fait c'est l'idée c'est
de partir tout seul avec une idée toute
bête qui est d'aller dormir chez des
gens que je rencontre dans tous les pays
du monde j'en suis à 62 pays et la
particularité tu le sais c'est que j'ai
fait mettre au point il ya vingtaine
d'années un équipement avec une petite
caméra ici qui filme les gens en face de
moi harnais à une tige notre caméra kim
film j'ai une troisième caméra à la main
et ce qui m'intéresse c'est la rencontre
c'est à dire le moment où tu rencontre
quelqu'un qui ne sait pas qui peut te
rends compte rester ville en est et tout
ça est filmée de manière objective les
mains sont libres regards et libre voilà
et cette émission ton personne n'a voulu
le début existe depuis 18 ans et elle
mange bien quand elle marche de rebond
voilà et alors justement par rapport au
concept même de l'émission qui est
indiqué dans le titre
tu ne souhaite pas spécialement en tout
cas à visiter dans le milieu les
monuments toi tu souhaite rencontrer les
gens et aller dormir chez eux
mais pourquoi vouloir dormir chez eux
par exemple pourquoi ne pas simplement
vouloir passer du temps avec eux allez
au restaurant tu le fais deux fois alors
il ya plein de raisons
d'abord ne pas aller voir ce qui est
beau dans un pays toutes ces choses là
ça a été fait mais il fois donc ça je
n'étais pas spécialement intéressé et
d'ailleurs dans cette émission y'a pas
de commentaire on te donne pas des infos
sur le pays combien qu'ont les habitants
la religion dominante tous ces trucs là
parce que de toute façon il ya ceux qui
retiennent ils le savent ce qu'ils
retiennent pas ils oublieront ça c'est
réglé ce qui m'intéressait c'est de
montrer quelque chose qu'on ne voyait
jamais c'est l'atmosphère des pays et
une atmosphère ça se raconte pas il faut
la laisser vivre donc ça c'est pourquoi
je me suis centré sur les gens ensuite
pourquoi aller dormir chez eux parce
qu'en fait cette émission mais ça c'est
quelque chose que je peux expliquer
aujourd'hui mais quand j'ai lancé le
concept si t'es pas analysé c'était je
sentais que c'est comme ça qu'il fallait
faire mais j'avais pas analysées
aujourd'hui je peux dire que l'intérêt
des missions séquelles à plein de
niveaux de lecture parce que c'est un
jeu est ce qui va arriver à dormir chez
les gens donc ça c'est très intéressant
comment vas tu faire comment il va faire
d'abord il va s'en sortir en allemand
j'aimerais aller suivre et donc je vous
donne mieux si je veux dire avec vous
non et puis c'est aussi un film d'
aventure parce que tout peut arriver y
ai vu des épisodes l'huile et les
fusillades il ya eu des épisodes lui on
a voulu me casser la figure et des
épisodes où je me suis retrouvé dans des
quartiers quand même très tendu et puis
il ya des moments qui sont magiques des
rencontres incroyables de de tendresse
de douceur de donc c'est aussi un film
d' aventure c'est quand même des
documentaires sur des pays parce que
quand on dit voilà l'idée moi ce que je
veux faire c'est partir dans des pays
allait dormir chez les gens au hasard on
te dis bon d'accord tu vas en faire
trois pays puis après ben et ben non on
en est à 62 parce que quand tu es au
japon n'a pas du tout du tout la même
chose qu'en ethiopie en suisse
même en france et donc pour répondre
donc à la question je redis pourquoi
dormir chez les gens parce que ça donne
ce côté jeux ludiques et qui fait que ça
participe au fait que tu suis cet
épisode est le fait de ne pas mettre de
commentaires aussi quand surtout à
l'époque où moi j'ai lancé cette
émission on n'arrêtait pas de m'emmerder
avec le commentaire et puis la musique
il fallait sans arrêt captivé capter
l'attention du spectateur je fais la
merde quand j'irai dormir chez vous il
n'ya jamais de trucs qui dit attention
il va se passer quelque chose mais tu
sais qu'il peut se passer quelque chose
et du coup les gens il bouffe l'écran
oui c'est une manière de capter
l'attention qui va totalement à
l'encontre des codes d'accès eux qui
vont chercher exactement et en plus de
ça nous on voit des choses que tu ne
vois pas puisque son nombre de caméras
fait qu'on a on voit ce qui se passe
presque derrière toi d'où l'écriture
d'un long métrage exactement parce que
c'est un élément très important du
scénario du film mais voilà je lui ai
posé une question en rapport avec la
notion de disponibilité c'est à dire
quand tu vas dans un pipe dans le cadre
de thé émission
toi ton but c'est qu'il arrive des
choses et donc tu te rends disponible à
tous oui la moindre personne qui passe
j'imagine qu'il doit y avoir des regards
thyssen capte aussi par moments ça donne
l'impression extérieurement que tout est
improvisé que ce n'est que pure
spontanéité et éviter a pas le droit de
dire ça c'est bêtement alors justement
pour vous ce soir spontanée ouais est ce
qu'il ne faut pas que son organisation
soit tellement millimétré c'est à dire
en termes de matériel avant d'allumer
les messieurs la batterie etc et que
c'est cette ultra organisation en un mot
nude qui rend possible ensuite parce
qu'on habite et honda disponibles nature
complètement je sais que j'ai une
particularité dans mon fonctionnement
c'est que je suis hyper brouillon et
hyper méthodique c'est à dire comme là
c'est le bordel et papiers sur la table
y en a partout mais je sais où ils ont
ça c'est une manière de gérer quand je
cherche un truc en général je ne cherche
pas longtemps je sais où il est parce
qu'ils limitent it rain est en fait pour
tourner j'irai dormir chez vous il faut
être comme ça c'est à dire qu'il faut
être hyper mais tonique avec la
technique tu dois pas laisser la part
à
l'improvisation avec la technique il
faut que ça marche il faut que ça soit
prêt et pour que ça marche c'est du
niveau de la check list c'est ce que
j'ai d'ailleurs pour partir en voyage du
pilote le pilote il a une check list ya
marqué sortir le train d'atterrissage on
est bien d'accord qui pourrait oublier
de sortir le train d'atterrissage enfin
on sait que c'est capital pour se poser
et si on l'a mis dans la check-list et
parce qu'un jour tu peux l'oublier ce
jour là ça aurait des conséquences très
bas moi si j'ai pas mal check list pour
être prêt et efficace et bien un jour ou
l'autre il ya un truc qui va pas marcher
je raté quelque chose et une fois que tu
as eu ce système là très méthodique qui
fonctionne tu peux complètement te
lâcher dans l'improvisation mais du
niveau de la dans la tête jamais cessé
complètement oublié parce que quand je
rencontre quelqu'un tu es obligé de
penser à la lumière dire si on est en
plein contre jour et que c'est
dégueulasse même si les caméras ont fait
des progrès incroyables à ce niveau là
mais il faut te démerder pour pivoter et
faire tourner le mec sans qu'ils s'en
rendent compte mais tout ça en discutant
avec lui et en pansement est ce qu a pas
trop de bruit et s'il n'y a pas un mec
derrière qui est en train d'arriver qui
va me faire un mauvais coup et en plus
de tout ça il faut te rendre sympathique
pour que le gars il a envie de
t'accueillir donc c'est une
ccsa beau être fantaisistes il faut
penser penser aux réponses et et ça
c'est bien d'être hyperactif
pour arriver à gérer tout ça et
d'ailleurs je pense pas à 50 mille
choses en même temps je pense à plein de
choses successivement mais très vite
et ce qui est amusant c'est que quand on
regarde les roches c'est à dire des
images brutes il ya des moments j'ai une
tête d'andouille parce que je pense à
autre chose donc j'écoute pas du tout de
mecs je repose la question qui est
laquelle il vient de répondre et
justement avec des ondes le message qui
enlève tout cela parce que j'avais
préparé une question dans ce sens je
vais me la poser maintenant ce sera fait
on a parfois l'impression
que tu ne sais pas trop où tu es que
mais complet de la situation des chapes
que tu es là un peu comme un chien dans
un jeu de qui est et pourtant tu as
l'habitude de voyager tu as l'habitude
d'être retrouvé dans cette situation là
donc ce que je voulais savoir c'est est
ce que ton habitude du voyage fait
qu'aujourd'hui tu te sens partout chez
toi ou pas chez moi c'est pas vraiment
le mot là je me sens vraiment chez moi
ici au sens de à l'aise comme chez moi
mais je me sens à l'aise oui mais chez
airbus a la bave épisode québec parce
qu'on est en train de voir et qui arrive
ce décodeur pour reprendre les premiers
épisodes et les augmenter en racontant
les bonus et commence à s'effacer et
c'est bon ça ça a l'air de bien partir
c'est intéressant et je revoyais la
séquence c'est deuxième épisode j'ai
rencontré une dame à l'église on
s'installe autour de sa table je pose
une caméra et puis on est en train de
manger tous les deux et à un moment mais
moi quand je le vois je rigole je me
lève et puis sans rien lui dire je vais
ouvrir un placard je prends je prends de
l'un vers des verts jeudi voulait nous
et l'hôtel est ahuri et quand je revois
la séquence encore aujourd'hui près de
20 ans après ça me fait marrer parce que
là tu vois vraiment un mec qui y est qui
est tellement à l'aise qui se pose pas
la question de savoir
s'il y va ou s'il va pas et c'est aussi
pour ça que ça passe
et versez-la
ça passe parce que c'est tellement fait
de manière spontanée est ce que je me
suis pas posé une seconde la question
pour terminer cette partie sur eux
jallet l'humain est ce que tu fais est à
la fois très aventureux va pas se mentir
de dire dans l'école conscient je pense
oui fait peu à peu et en même temps ce
qui te plaît c'est la normalité ou
l'ordi narith et de la vie des gens et
arrive à rendre ça
captivant d'où ma question un peu
philosophique est-ce que l'ordi n'a ri
té est une aventure
alors ça c'est vraiment de la
philosophie je ne sais pas si je vais
pas répondre salle
ah ça mais le moi ce que j'ai constaté
c'est que le fait que tu découvres cette
rencontre en temps réel fait que la
personne qu'on rencontre elle
t'intéresse quelle qu'elle soit quelles
qu'elles soient alors que quand tu vois
dans un documentaire qu on te met
quelqu'un à l'image tout à coup on te
voilà un mec qui va comment on dit par
exemple
on va aller voir le ferronnier du
village - truc comme ça et que toute
rencontre le ferronnier d'un seul coup
le gars il commence à te parler ça
sous-entend que cette personne là a été
étudiée avant et que
honteux on sait déjà qu'elle est
intéressante ça sous-entend ça alors que
moi celle inverse j'ai d'une part la
rencontre et puis je ne coupe jamais
l'entrée dans la maison le parce que
c'est ça qui te qui te captifs qui est
de faire entrer dans l'histoire et quand
le mec tu commence à le connaître et bah
t'as envie d'en savoir plus même s'il
est l'ordinaire c'est simplement s'il ya
toute la soirée derrière ça tiendra pas
l'alluré voilà alors je vais lui repose
la question l'ordinateur grundy moi
parce que l'ordinaire est une aventure
est-ce que l'ordinaire été une aventure
ça dépend aussi de ta manière de
l'aborder c'est à dire que mon moi je
sais pour les problèmes pour jeter paris
d'ailleurs de penser à plein de trucs et
tout c'est que je ne vais pas faire
attention à tout ce qui est ordinaire
chez une personne ordinaire mais s'il ya
un moment il ya quelque chose dans son
environnement qui moi me semble sortir
de l'ordinaire ou être incohérent avec
la personne ça je le vois tout de suite
et c'est la même chose dans la rue je me
balade dans la rue la rue c'est
ordinaire mais quand il ya un petit truc
qui sort de l'ordinaire je le vois et je
vais voir et souvent c'est comme ça que
tu tombes sur quelqu'un qui sort du lot
très bien alors je faisais beaucoup de
pays dont tu vas rencontrer de nombreux
spas pleuvent et us et souvent ce qu'on
entend dire par rapport aux cultures on
dit il ya des préjugés sur telle ou
telle culture ou tel pays est la
question que je me pose est simple
est-ce que les préjugés parfois se
confirmant bien sûr bien sûr il est prêt
à gibier qui se confirme par exemple on
dit au japon
tu vas pas chez les gens on va pas chez
les gens au japon très peu très peu mais
ce qui est assez intéressant puisqu'on
parle du préjugé c'est le préjugé ça
sous-entend que tu as appris des choses
sur un pays avant d'y aller eh ben ça
c'est ce que je refuse de faire avec
j'irai dormir chez vous je ne prépare
pas et pourquoi c'est une vraie raison
est sage et pas forcément comprise et le
début mais maintenant je peut l'analyser
c'est que si tu prépares par exemple
quand écrit un scénario qui est pas
vraiment un scénario main le texte d'un
documentaire le dossier tu vas te tue va
préparer pour préparer tu vas te
renseigner pour te renseigner tu va
regarder tu vas prendre de la
documentation la documentation c'est les
autres qui ont fait un travail sur le
même pays avant que toi et ils ont fait
la même chose or toute cette cascade de
gens qui travaillent sur le travail des
précédents ont été influencés par ce
travail des précédents c'est à dire que
quand tu vas dans un pays tu arrives
dans le pays pour faire le tournage et
que tu as écrit tourre dossier et bah tu
essayes de faire ce que tu as écrit
c'est logique complètement naturel mais
tu as été influencé par avec qui avait
fait la même chose qui avait fait la
même chose et c est bien le problème
c'est que tu arrive avec des idées
anciennes très ancienne alors que quand
t'as rien préparé
tu prends le pays dans la gueule comme
il est et tu vas découvrir des choses
qui sont pas du tout ce que les gens te
disent et ces choses là tu vas les voir
alors que si tu es arrivé avec tes idées
préconçues et bah tu vas voir les autres
choses et je trouve que justement enfin
c'était ma manière de répondre à ta
question sur le
les idées des idées préconçues et sais
c'est que c'est bien d'en avoir le moins
possible mais pour en avoir le moins
possible il faut avoir le moins préparé
possible son pays son voyage prénom est
ce que tu dirais que de ce que tu en as
vu l'être humain est le même partout
attention je précise parce que il ya des
différences évidemment culturel mais est
ce que tu dis densifier une sorte de
dénominateur commun à tous les peuples
coutu a un certain nombre il ya un
certain
mina teurs comme un cas
l'envi de d'élever ses enfants
bien envie de passer du temps et que tes
amis ça c'est très commun de rire etc
mais il est allé les codes sociaux sont
pas les mêmes dans tous les pays et il
ya quand même d'aider des civilisations
août à moi envie de rire que d'autres ou
et parfois tuent en inde par exemple
c'était assez surprenant quand moi je
rencontrais des gens comme ça au hasard
et il m'arrivait un truc qui est assez
français européen et c'est quand tu
rencontres quelqu'un qui sait pas trop
quoi lui dire tu es un petit sorte de
rire nerveux qui veut dire qui veut dire
mon népote où tu tu essayes de placer le
truc comme ça en inde c'était presque
systématique pourquoi tu ris parce qu'il
avait plus l'impression que tu riais
deux peut-être ou alors en tout cas il
comprenait pas pourquoi tu riais et il
voulait savoir tu vois alors que tu
rencontres quelqu'un t'a jamais vu tu te
retrouve nez à nez je sais pas quoi et
tu fais un petit e
comme ça juste ça t'a pas gris métal aux
initiés une direction à la rencontre qui
va vers le rire la sympathie la fusion
l'amitié ce que tu veux barnum ça ça
marchait pas bien pas le même code non
voilà même code ok et elle est arrivée à
rire mais c'était pas comme ça le cadet
il ya des constantes enfin des choses
déjà constaté lendemain tous un peu les
mêmes envies quand même sur la plaine en
fait je vais dire un truc des vrais
méchants sur la planète y en a
pratiquement pas il ya des gens qui sont
dans ici les situations très difficiles
qui les pousse à s'en sortir pas
gentiment mais des gens qui sont
fondamentalement miche méchant c'est à
dire qui ils auraient ils auraient
justement la caméra qui veulent te voler
ta volerait pas
est ce qu'antoine de maximy à une zone
de confort
probable mais c'est certainement pas
quelque chose que je cherche à cultiver
pour te vieille idée quand je me suis
installé avec la mère de ma fille
je l étais jeune avec 22 23 ans j'avais
dix ans de plus soit et c'était dans
cette maison d'ailleurs parce que là on
a l'impression que c'est ton travaux et
que ça fait trop en plus tranquille et
la maison mais ça m'intéresse moi la
déco tout ça non je m'en fous et
premier s'habituer la fusion j'y vois la
deuxième fois bien tu veux la fusion et
bah ouais troisième salle des turbines a
fait je dirais ton produit infusion tous
les soirs et voit la routine je ne
supporte pas ce à quoi
j'essaie de ne pas faire deux fois la
même chose dans ma vie presque aller
d'abord je me lève tous les matins je me
lavais truc comme ça mais
je me bats contre ça et elle parce
qu'elle était jeune donc elle est c'est
bon on a découvert qu'elle vit on
voulait avoir on est toujours en très
bons termes mais à la vie qui est pas du
tout la mienne et moi j'ai une vie qui
est pas du tout est la sienne et
d'ailleurs elle m'a fait un des plus
beaux compliments qu'une femme est fait
dans toute ma vie c'est quand on s'est
séparés en bons termes elle m'a dit
enfin aujourd'hui va ressembler à demain
eh ben ça pour moi c'est un compliment
voilà et est-ce que des sentiments ou
des émotions comme la gêne l'embarras ou
la timidité sont des sentiments que tu
connais oui que j'ai connu à mais que je
connais plus beau coup que tu connais
plus beaucoup non parce que alors c'est
vrai c'est jeudi regagne les années il
ya de l'expérience tu vois maintenant
évident d'expérience et rien à faire
mais
tu t'aperçois que à peu près quoi qu'il
arrive si tu affrontes le truc et tout
battez pas ridicule en fait de pas
ridicule c'est c'est ce qu'ils vont
vouloir te tourner en ridicule que tu
peux retourner
que tu peut même rendre ridicule mais
oui quand on assume ces radios 100 %
mais quand tu assumes déjà été rarement
ridicule continuation plutôt plus un peu
excentré bizarre aux yeux des autres
mais c'est vrai ouais et puis surtout tu
peux vraiment rigolé 500 plus quand tu
es dans l'autodérision et moi je suis
vraiment là dedans c'est à dire que rire
c'est prioritaire ça passe à avant le
fait de pas passer pour un con c'est à
dire que si en passant pour un con ça
fait marrer tout le monde moi ça me fait
rire aussi quoi
là aussi je vais faire un petit vient
alors je sais pas si tu connais l'auteur
nicolas bouvier oui alors m'a donné elle
et son livre je n'ai pas lu parce que là
je lis jamais à bec ou si tu le lis un
jour peut-être il est là où le premier
du monde l usage du monde oui voilà et y
il dit dans un passage de se disent
quelque chose que je trouve intéressant
je voulais de soumettre c'est que il
voit le voyage comme quelque chose qui
va user son ego au point que finalement
il devient presque le monde quoi sa
personnalité salut elle vient d'un
philosophe moi non justement eh ben est
ce que toi tu es amateurs de récits de
voyage d'ailleurs est ce que les
voyageurs sont amateurs de récits de
voyage ou est-ce que bah je pense que
oui alors moi j'ai été énormément
amateurs de récits de voyages terre le
bouquin de nicolas bouvier si je l'avais
connu quand je suis même pas quand il a
écrit mais 63 donc j'aurais pu lire dans
les années 70 75 donc j'avais une
quinzaine d'années
j'aurais j'en ai lu énormément parce que
je me rendais pas compte ça me faisait
rêver ça m'emmenait et puis je pensais
peut-être que j'allais voyager mais
j'étais pas du tout déjà prêt à ça mais
en revanche j'ai toujours vu ses
bouquins là comme des cours magistraux
que l'âge arriver à suivre sur un sujet
qui m'intéressait vraiment c'était
qu'est ce que je ferai dans telle
situation et d'ailleurs je sais que
beaucoup de gens regardant j'irai dormir
chez vous on s'est tu cette réflexion
c'est comment je réagirais six mois ont
sonné à ma porte ou comment je réagirais
si moi je me retrouvais dans ce quartier
est donc mais ce boulot car là je n'ai
pas lu je sais même pas si il m'aurait
intéressé parce que apparemment il est
moins sûr ce qui lui arrive que sur ses
réflexions intéressant ça c'est plus
l'analyse je sais pas si cela
l'intéressé on a offert dédicacé et tout
mais à l'occasion on reviendra ici pour
que tu ne dises ton avis là dessus
est ce que tu te considères comme
quelqu'un d'audacieux est pour toi
qu'est-ce que l'audace alors est ce que
je suis et ce que je sais pas parce que
apparemment oui par rapport à plein de
gens je suis audacieux
mais je suis extrêmement prudent je suis
très très prudent on s'en rend pas
forcément compte mais avec tout ce que
j'ai fait parce que là on parle de
j'irai dormir chez vous mais moi avant
je suis descendu dans des volcans je
suis descendu dans les gouffres de glace
de la calotte glaciaire du groenland
j'éprouve pour gyan sous marin 5000 m je
suis allé sur les arbres en amazonie et
que le radeau des cimes il faut regarder
sur internet le radeau des cimes je peux
raconter mais le radeau des cimes c'est
ouais tout ces expéditions là moi on est
dans des endroits qui étaient très
dangereux mais avec des dangers qui
était
qui était que tu pouvais plus facilement
gérer c'est à dire si tu t'attaches pas
bien tu vas tomber des trucs comme ça
mais j'ai toujours été très très prudent
et j'ai d'autres particularités c'est
que j'ai jamais rien fait pour rien
c'est à dire quand je suis descendue
dans des falaises c'était pour filmer et
quand les autres voulu y retourner pour
faire un peu d'escaladé j allais pas
c'était un risque inutile pour moi je ne
prenais pas ce genre de risques alors
l'audace la définition au mois ces
dictionnaires en général donc
l'audace
je bats toi je regarde la définition
exacte soit pour moi l'audace c'est
c'est prendre un certain nombre de
risques mais très calculé ça c'est mes
parents aussi moi je fils de deux
peintres oui on les avait d'ailleurs
voilà qui était assez oui dans le tedx
de marseille qui était assez
anticonformiste et ils m'ont appris une
chose mes parents nous ont jamais appris
on a appris en or mimétisme en voyant
comment il fonctionnait etc mais il
partait pas du principe ça ne se fait
pas ça c'est un truc qui n'existaient
pas c'est pourquoi ça se ferait pas tout
voir et tout le temps je me suis
toujours posé la question des caisses
qui m'empêche de faire ça quand je me la
pose la question je fais pas n'importe
quoi sans réfléchir mais je je
j'exclus le moins possible parce que je
suis sûr que j'exclus des choses par
principe
semble poser la question mais pour moi
probablement beaucoup moins que d'autres
donc oui de ge et de l'audace
je me dis moi il n'y a rien qui
m'empêche de faire ça ça ne se fait pas
on s'en fout de ce fait pas surtout que
ce qui se faisait pas une époque se fera
exemple tout con mais le craps as mangé
pas au québec il ya 50 ans oui c'est la
phrase tu sais il ne savait pas que
c'était impossible donc ils l'ont fait
et voilà on en reparlera si tu veux bien
on terminera peut-être même l'entretien
là dessus jusqu'avant une petite
parenthèse tu as fait en 2020 une petite
série de vidéos sur youtube ah oui
pendant continuellement voilà gérer
rajeunir chez vous ou du justement je le
raconte un peu tout ce que tu as fait
par le passé les aventures que tu as
vécu et alors tu nous présente un
personnage qui s'appelle chaumont oui
est ce que tu peux nous parler
brièvement de chou à chaud moselle était
un mec absolument incroyable j'ai
rencontré il avait 70 ans je pense moi
j'en avais eu
à 25 c'est mon père en fait qu'il y a qu
il a rencontrés et c'était un sculpteur
qu'est-ce que ça ne
s'est pas exactement je suis la forme de
la pierre et puis la pire elle-même ce
qui est très important c'est que la
pierre elle mène elle veut elle-même
devenir quelque chose et moi je ne peux
pas imposer ma volonté est la pierre la
pire elle va devenir quelque chose c'est
à dire indépendamment ma volonté à moi
chaque pierre chaque chose comme ça elle
a un devenir un devenir qu'on appelle ça
du domaine de l'inconscient et en lieu
on lui fait pas faire ce que l'on veut
on suit vous suit je pense que c'est un
des plus gros créateur que je connaisse
parce que là on n'engage que moi mais je
les assume
quant à un picasso qui a fait plein de
trucs dont tout le monde s'accorde à
dire que c'était un génie moi je trouve
pas du tout que c'est un génie il a il a
trois quatre grandes périodes dans sa
vie que juger vraiment survolé dont je
donnerai aucune leçon là dessus mais ça
ne m'attire pas du tout garni calais et
j'en ai vu que très peu tu vois j'ai pas
pris le temps il ya son cheval il est
super bien ce cheval en un seul trait et
c'est ok mais chomo c'était un mec qui
était dix fois plus yann parce que
c'était un créateur mais c'était une
foisonnement créa de créativité il
visait comme un ermite dans la forêt
fontainebleau il bouffe et des restes de
boîtes de conserve qui trouvait il vous
fait dans les poubelles en fait c'est
comme ça mais moi j'ai voulu faire un
film sur ce gars parce que j'avais pu le
rencontrer grâce à mon père donc mais du
temps il n'a pas accepté tout de suite
de mauvais la porte mais
je louer le matériel et chaque fois que
je revenais pour faire un petit bout de
tournage de complément je revenais il
avait re développer un nouveau type de
sculptures de peinture de musique de
tout ce que tu veux mais avec une
technique qui n'avait rien à voir avec
le précédent alors la saison les
grillages des grillages mode l'écraser
l'exhibent le grillage fait une fois en
grillage après ça je pas les morceaux du
gic ou des bouts de plastique que se
font au chalumeau quand c'est mou et
bien figé des cailloux du phare monde
est d'aider les assiettes cassées du
tout et ça colle dans le plastique comme
ça oui la servante olivier et où ça fait
ça fait au crâne c'était un créateur qui
partaient dans tous les sens et à chaque
fois je re louer le matériel parce que
j'utilisais ça ne peut pas ne pas être
dans le fuit c'était un vraiment un
génie et cder faut regarder ce film
chomo c'est un show et mots qu'on trouve
sur internet will que tu m'aimes
gracieusement offert à youtube oui oui
oui je veux que je lis je n'ai pas payé
pour faire ce film
ça va coûter des sceaux mais j'ai trouvé
que le retour c'était que ceux ci ne
soient accessibles à tous
et ce mec est absolument génial alors
oui je tiens fous ces thèmes et mais
comment tu veux pas voir la manie qu'il
a eue sans être minimum de folie quoi
dans ce mec génial en tout cas quelqu'un
dont on se souvient oui mais qui est au
dessus de vraiment là beaucoup beaucoup
d'artistes reconnus aujourd'hui oui oui
là donc on voit qu'on peut faire sur un
essai d'été tout avec des bouts de
télévision qui s'est fondée il faut il
faut voir et d'ailleurs il a une
philosophie qu'il essaie de transmettre
tombe bien que mal c'était quoi déjà
j'ai appris un jour en sculpture j'avais
fait une sculpture concrète avec mon
idée d' imbéciles d'hommes et de mon
raisonnement d'hommes et puis on m'a
appelé la sculpture est tombé à l'envers
egis aperçu que mon en verre était plus
sérieux et plus beau que mon endroit mon
endroit c'est mon raisonnement est
l'envers de cette culture si
l'inconscient tu as compris c'est
important ça mais moi je voudrais un
jour j'attends d'être plus riche et plus
connu surtout de julia une fondation
pour la faire je sais très bien comment
la faire grâce à ce que disait chomo il
m'a jamais dit fais ça moi je veux faire
une fondation pour la la la france peut
devenir je ne peux devenir un le pays de
l'art si on faisait ça mais je ne le dis
pas maintenant c'est pas le moment mais
j'ai mes idées et à j'ignorais que tu
avais un regard si particulier sur l'art
et le monde à me joindre et c'est de la
merde c'est non non pas l'art le milieu
le commerce de l'art d'ailleurs c'est ce
qui lie dans le fait est là on n'est pas
fait pour être vendus bah oui mais ça
marche comme ça malheureusement sur la
planète mais sincèrement
je sais très bien que je suis pas un
spécialiste mais je sais qu'on les gens
qui sont des marchands d'art créé une
cote sur un artiste donc le mec a un nul
c'est pas ça je veux dire mais on va on
va parce que pour faire de l'argent donc
il faut que ces oeuvres valent de plus
en plus cher pour gagner de l'argent si
la spéculation quand donc ça n'a pas plu
voilà j'ai pas plus de considération
pour ça que pour la bourse eh ben c'est
clair césar franck c'est de la musique
de fonctionnaires c'est de la musique de
chevaux de bois bat compagnie c'est la
même chose
il ya un type qui a atteint des degrés
peut-être très élevé c'est dans le
prélude de lohengrin avec wagner quand
wagner en parle un petit peu moi ça me
ça me fout la sphère de poule comme on
dit où ça fait remonter les couilles ça
fait de l'effet le reste c'est de la
merde c'est du raisonnement par exemple
la musique c'est un giga qui est tout
seul en ce moment c'est le printemps les
lui sont belles sa femme l'abandonner il
prend son violon ou tard les tripes
c'est ça la musique on arrive lentement
sur la fin de cet entretien alors je
voulais qu'on revienne justement
sur quelque chose que tu as beaucoup
développée dans ta conférence ted qui a
été lié à la persévérance et au fait de
concrétiser ses rêves on dit souvent
c'est bien de rêver l'espoir fait vivre
c'est ce qui nous place toujours dans
une espèce de monde imaginaire quoi mais
on concrétise beaucoup moins à ce propos
est ce que tu pourrais rappelé
l'anecdote de ceux de cet homme qui
voulait un voilier ah oui
oui les rêves les rêves
bon alors l'anecdote du gars qui voulait
un voilier s'est effectivement donc un
mec qui avait pas d'argent qui voulait
un voilier qui a repéré un voilier dans
le port dans un port je sais pas lequel
qui était qui est écoulé une coque mais
ma y avait plus de mal et elle était à
deux mètres 3 mètres de fond rien et il
s'est dit je vais prendre des bidons et
gelé les mettre dans donc il plonge avec
des bidons vides ce qui n'est pas
évident de lui peut-être qu'ils se les
steaks des cailloux j'ai pu le détail et
il remettait des bidons dans le voilier
et il s'est dit quand il y en aura
suffisamment il va remonter et
complètement logique et il passait des
journées entières à faire ça quand ils
étaient crevés l'arrêter mais enfin il
venait tous les jours tous les jours
tous les jours et puis mais en fait il a
fini par avoir un voilier mais postule
il a fini par avoir un voilier parce
qu'il a discuté avec un mec qui était
sur le port un vieux puits sont philippe
à retenir copains puis chaque jour dont
ils vouvoyaient descendre c'est bidon et
tout est un jour il lui a dit écoute moi
je suis vieux j'ai pas d'héritier j'ai
envoyé je te dois je repartirai plus là
et il a eu un voilier et ça ça c'est une
vraie démonstration que quand tu as
envie de quelque chose il faut même si
tu sais pas comment tu vas y arriver que
tu sens que tu pourrais y arriver il
faut y aller il faut y aller faut y
aller parce que il ya des choses des
portes qui vont s'ouvrir des choses qui
vont arriver peut-être qu'il aurait
trouvé une technique pour remplir son
voilier d'air en une fois qu'ils
auraient été du foot une énorme poche
par exemple ait trouvé une bombe qui
envoyaient de l'air dedans il y avait
cinquante mille trucs mais tu sais pas
mais il faut y aller et de toute façon
en règle générale quand tu te bats pour
faire des choses si tu n'obtiens pas ce
que tu voulais tu obtiendras quelque
chose et beaucoup plus que ceux qui se
poseraient est quelque chose que tu
n'avais même pas envisagé au départ
c'est aussi ça la beauté de ce genre la
ville donne quand elles sont réelles
c'est qu'on prend un chemin sans savoir
qu au bout de ce chemin il y en a un
autre oui car on n'avait pas pensé on ne
peut le savoir que lorsqu'on entreprend
livre alors le drame c'est que parfois
ce chemin qui le mène dans des mauvais
endroit je sais pas mais s'il a vite
intéresse plus en prenant des chemins
qui ne connaît pas mais faut le faire si
la ville t'intéresse pas comme ça il
faut pas y aller moi je dit pas aux gens
partaient comme ça en amazonie au hasard
il va ça va être super non il faut que
tu le sentais que ce soit vraiment une
volonté profonde est vraiment
intrinsèque et parmi ces gens là y'en a
qui sont jamais revenus donc non il fait
je dois déjà mes conseils je donne
jamais conseil il faut que vraiment ça
vienne de l'intérieur mais le rêve le
rêve ce que ça c'était ça le départ de
la question c'est c c'est super
important c'est ce et c'est bien de
rêver et moi ce que je trouve top c'est
l'arrivée à rêver à avoir tes rêves et à
essayer dé concrétiser en étant
cartésien en n'étant pas que rêveur le
rêve c'est ce qui donne qui donne la
direction la porte etc mais si t'es pas
cartésien et salons te dis un peu il ya
parfois du mépris des rêveurs pour les
cartésiens avoir le linverse c'est
vachement bien c'est d'être les deux
parce que le rêve tfue qui va te faire
partir et le cartésien c'est ce qui va
t'aider à arriver
parce que rêver ça va pas forcément tu
m'aider loin et cartésien gaza au point
de faire marrer mais plein de fois dans
ma vie il m'est arrivé d'avoir des idées
ça soit celle de la série j'irai dormir
chez vous que ce soit le long métrage de
fiction sur la série gérer dormir chez
vous et bien pareil personne n'a voulu
de ce film et ça aurait pu rester un une
idée en l'air c'est à dire que en fait
c'est confortable de rêver c'est très
confortable et de te dire je vais
concrétiser mon rêve
là tu rentres dans la difficulté tu
rentres dans dans ces difficiles
d'ailleurs j'ai un pareil qui est un
petit peu
qui est qui est vrai quand j'ai fait mon
mes premiers documentaires et surtout le
premier qui était qui était d'ailleurs
le premier vraiment que j'ai produit et
où c'était chaud mots oui eh ben tant
que tu es en train de tourner
c'est quand même dans leurs rêves parce
que tu vas faire un film mais le jour où
tu dit j'arrête de tournai et maintenant
je vais monter le fils il ya plus de
phrases comme on arrange raza au montage
maintenant on va arranger c'est au
montage et là tu rentres dans la réalité
de ton film que tu vas faire avec
uniquement ce que tu as et ben c'est un
peu la même chose le tournage c'est pas
mal le rêve même si tu essayes de faire
les choses et le montage c'est le pied
du mur c'est le réel tel pied du mur si
on voulait extraire un message de ton
émission qu'est ce que ce serait alors
j'en sais rien moi si je devais moi
décider
j'ai juste envie qu'on se fasse plaisir
en les regardant mais je sais que c'est
ça je veux dire le retour des gens
d'abord parce que c'est grave quand j'ai
cru que tu en mets tu ne te regarde pas
mais il y en a beaucoup qui est le
regard est qui et qui me disent merci ça
ça fait quand même plaisir que dans la
rue quelqu'un à merci merci merci ça
fait très plaisir en revanche mais moi
j'ai pas revendiquer sa on m'a dit mais
beaucoup de gens me l'ont dit que cette
émission était un pont entre les hommes
que ça permettait de voir que en été on
avait des constantes comme on n'en a
parlé tout à l'heure je dire qu'on aime
aimer élever ses enfants etc on a des
constantes et qu'on n'est pas si éloigné
d'une culture à l'autre et c'est
ça mais moi je suis pas du tout partie
pour faire cette émission en me disant
je vais faire une émission pour jeter
des ponts entre les hommes non c'est
parce que moi je suis fondamentalement
comme ça quand je rentre dans une
boulangerie j'ai tendance à parler à vos
voisins que j'ai jamais vue sans essayer
du tout capter son regard ni rien je je
je suis comme ça je suis très
naturellement pour entre les gens et moi
quand j'ai fait cette émission je
voulais faire une émission qui ont envie
de regarder
et qui était
et qui était qui était marrante quoi qui
était dit il ouais c'est ça c'est tout
est-ce que tu aurais un message pour le
coup à faire passer un autre spectateur
évidemment évidemment et règle ses
découvertes maintenant parce qu'en fait
j'irai dormir chez vous c'était sur
france 5 mais bon t'as pas continuer et
moi j'avais envie de continuer donc j'ai
trouvé à elle s'est découvert qu'ils
étaient ravis de reprendre l'émission
donc bon vous aurez un petit peu de pub
avait blessé comme ça c'est pas
l'armement mais en revanche plus de
des épisodes arrivée des rediffs en ce
moment et c'est tous les vendredis soirs
à 21h sur rmc découverte canal 24 c'est
gratuit c'est la tnt et on veut et
surtout est un petit est un petit scoop
on en train de préparer des
on va reprendre les anciens j'irai
dormir chez vous les premiers qui sont
pas passés depuis 15 ans au moins
et on va les augmenter
c'est à dire qu'on va se retrouver dans
cette cuisine où là c'est vraiment mal à
ces mots qg et je vais raconter les
coulisses de ses voyages là et je vais
les décortiquer les analyser et le
premier épisode hors jeu pas comme ça
mais c'est pour bientôt un
ça va être le mali le premier épisode
que j'ai tourné c'était le mali je
savais même pas si j'allais arriver à
voir un film et je peux te dire que
quand tu sors la première fois de
l'hôtel avec ton matériel dans la rue il
ya plein de gens qui voient un étranger
à mâcher comme ça et qui te regardent
comme ça tu as un peu envie de retourner
dans l'hôtel donc voilà je vais raconter
tout ça pour bien parfait rendez vous
est pris merci vous contera bas merci
c'était très bien
coupez
[Musique]